greetings from podcast Ville it's Monday
the 23rd of December you bad
[ __ ] the Church of what's
happening now is brought to you by
upstart most of us find it hard getting
into death is easy getting out of debt
that's hard especially if your credit
card if your credit score isn't that
great they offer you a smaller interest
rates to help you pay off your credit
card debt that's what upstart does you
understand me they consolidate and they
get your party started and they go
beyond that then the traditional credit
score you with upstart your interest
rating is based on your education job
history
not your credit score so do me a favor
right now upstart is ranked number one
in that category with over 300
businesses on Trustpilot Harry table
start com / Church CH you are CH to find
out how low your up start ranking be
start the year off what up start
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes and it won't affect your credit
that's upstart com / Church it's also
brought to you by this is the gift
you're sitting there scratching your
head it's Monday like what am i yelling
at my grandmother you ready a portable
bidet you're like why wouldn't my
grandmother in the important birthday
because their ass smells like a goat
that's why next time you go over for
Christmas dinner look at your
grandmother's ass and just play with
Beatty for a minute and say to yourself
what does it with her mufflers my wife
she's 82 listen y'all ain't joy what's a
bad day
it sprinkles water into your muffler
clean water the same water you brush
your teeth with not toilet water we'll
get all that stuff later I'm just trying
to educate you right now
they started $79 and they called tushies
okay
and tushies don't play games why because
it makes your wall already off the dot
when you buy a tooshie you're telling me
you give a [ __ ] about the environment
you'd really bastard after all just wipe
your ass - trees are dying in my
neighborhood because you want to dry
your [ __ ] hedge riot [ __ ] old school I
like the Quakers dead you know I'm
saying anyway right now
and gets 10% off your first door to get
a bidet started let's get this party
started you got how you gonna get you a
little muffler licked if it's not gonna
be clean if you got UTIs and all that
stuff and let's face it some people
waiting for Santa Claus some people
waiting to somebody just bump into you
licking that second stuck that tongue up
your muffling my Randy yeah I'm waiting
for someone to lick my balls huh this is
what I'm talking about here so go -
hello - she calm / Church it's Monday
the 23rd to get Jackie Gleason's to get
Santa Claus it's all about you kick this
melee everybody's jumping up and down
it's Christmas we don't give a [ __ ] you
the church what's happen I understand me
or we care about this today my girls
here and he let him in looking
spectacular top comedian savage gangster
from Philly part-time Quaker the whole
thing drop it on me beauty I'm a violent
Quaker so drop low do what's happening
all right I just it's it is am I allowed
to tell the world that it's Sunday it's
whatever you want we're recording on a
Sunday I came from church that's right I
came from Quaker meeting I came from
church to go to church but food churches
of one did I double church together by
that means I can do its you can do
whatever the [ __ ] I want
now what better say Peter I'm gonna go
rob a [ __ ] Bank talk to the guy blind
he's got the ticket go punching all boys
what's going on beautiful uh nothing I'm
feeling good I uh you're one of those
girls that doesn't wear makeup and looks
good like on so he had like you have
makeup it just a torture I'm wearing so
much makeup makeup on you just was
stunning just stunning yeah you try to
be camera-ready yeah I try to make them
you know ready I'm ready I'm ready
manager my comment I smell good I look
good I'm funny I try have fun your art
of a good time I got to take my little
Church name tag off I saw that I saw
like that that was like a thing from
month
you want to visit a prisoner in jail I
don't know I don't know you deal is how
are you I'm good I'm good what's going
on these days these
today's just comedy comedy it's so much
fun I had a good a good weekend I did
some Special K and I listened to some
self out books and got special okay it's
like a rave drug but now they use for
PTSD and depression
it's a disassociative so it it gives you
perspective you can like look at things
from an outside point of view just like
Reef yeah well sort of it's a
tranquilizer are you uh are you a lonely
I fought him it lasts like an hour I
think that's it yeah but the results
it's they use a lot for people that it's
like antidepressants right away you know
you have to wait for an antidepressant
to kick in and stuff it's like okay it's
it just it is supposed to like reinstate
the neuro pathways in your brain
pharmaceutical or I mean I don't do it I
mean I do a raver style okay but they
have they're like trying to get a I
think they just passed an inhaler so
you're just snoring it's like no you
know that they're finding out all these
things now about mushrooms people are
micro doses yeah how's that depression
whatnot you know man when I was at my
darkest point I couldn't figure out life
like I might sound like a loser for
saying this the reason why I'm his
cousin yeah
when I lost my mother at sixteen I won
in a year and a half acid trip looking
for an answer
mm-hm it was I was looking for an answer
took my mind and took it somewhere I
didn't want to be and it and gave you
answers and every day gave me another
day like alright tomorrow I'll take
another hit and we'll pick up where we
left off yeah you know it was such a
deep thread going on in my life and I
know that somewhere along the line it's
beneficial
it wasn't beneficial how I was doing it
I'm gonna scientists I can't sit here
entire you know we bumped into somebody
who explained ketamine to us that's kind
of mean who said yes kind of mean that
you know it helps to pressure and all
this stuff you know I gotta be strictly
honest see here's another drug I gotta
tell you that was horrible it's
horrible drug well when I was on I was
focused that's what I did that's that's
okay I did a line of coke you can't get
more focused in there for me coke just
like it's it's it's not it's not my drug
no it's nobody's drug well I'm like I'm
nobody sure I'm sober other than
ayahuasca DMT acid mushrooms a lot of
things Special K coke you won't do a
line
I won't you come you won't do a vicodin
you won't do an oxy well it depends on
if I drink no I don't drink
you don't drink drinking you're doing
this stuff I'm trying to like things
exactly that teach me open you up a
little bit you know when you age and I
I'd say this with confidence and I don't
want people to fool me or jump off a
building or criticize me sometimes me
and me you're [ __ ] around and we'll
do it we'll drop and hit a sit or
something and it takes me somewhere
different because Leo say like I walked
all night man and I think only an hour
giggle because fully it's something
different than what it is for me we were
talking to my mindset the last podcast
how you looking things yeah you're gonna
go follow louis c.k and Chris Rock
you're driving thinking you're gonna die
you know man like I gotta go follow Luis
yeah I think Chris Rock is going up and
then I'm going up yeah I'm glad it means
go yeah on the drive down there you're
gonna lose your money I lose but you
might program your mindset yeah you know
that you might just go down that rock
yeah it's how you going there you go in
there with your shoulders slumped well
I'm gonna die already you're gonna die
you're gonna die so it's the mindset
yeah when I do it any type of those
things like I could look in the face
tell you I've done over on us a hundred
acid trips I never had a bad trip yeah
when people say bad roads like I always
say explain to me what it is because all
these medicines give you what you need
it's like what are you talking about a
bad trippity breathe man just bad
trapeze you saw the truth yeah you
didn't want to see it you don't want
well tell me this don't you see this
like hallucinogens have taught me that
life is like as equally hideous as it is
gorgeous so it's like it's the same
thing so it's like it does hurt but
also you have to feel that pain to feel
the like beautiful fizzle of like the
light - it's the same thing when my
mother died I had such a void and the
only thing that filled it there was two
things that felt it my friends in the
daytime and then once I went home at
night those four walls got smaller I am
an advocate for people with a touch of
mental health to get our lives I have a
touch of mental health issues I had a
lot of mental issues for me to survive I
know I gotta get out loud yeah because
the walls are closing up yeah and you'll
think about the bad stuff my dad always
tells me whenever I'm depressed he's
like go out and he's like go talk to
strangers or whatever which is honestly
how I got molested as a kid but it's
good advice as a girl but it really is
true it's like I I am a social I really
like to talk to people I really I mean
I'm just going around chatting with
people all day well you know depression
starts by sleeping later you know you
look at all the symptoms at first it
opens up with sleep sluggishness you're
tired you know and then the walls start
creeping in on you and then you have to
do something about it yeah go talk to
somebody get medication but I would
start with vitamin D yeah it's the cure
that's the noun that's that's the you
know natural cure we're talking about
decorative item in the Sun would you go
you back both ways you just won I don't
mean to be blue you know everyone thinks
I'm a lesbian
I just buy I don't know Tim Dylan told
me that I should say that I'm bi so that
I can say all the words yeah you get
away with murder
so I'm buying yeah okay bye I just
thought that you were like that I I have
a lot of respect we I never thought
nothing of you sexually I just thought
that you were just with girls oh really
yeah well I don't I try it I don't like
the taste I don't care one way or
another I love the taste to it you don't
say that's a good thank you
like calories taste well no I I always
say that uh because I was on the boys
baseball team and stuff I had brother so
I was
always like competing as a boy with
everyone so I did all these things and
it's like as I was saying like instead
of a Deadpool they had a dyke pool like
everyone was like just betting on how
gay I was going to be and then I wasn't
going
it's a beautiful to be gay look at you I
got fingered once by a girl who looked
like a boy but I wasn't
really yeah I'm how 24 why did she
finger you make she just looked like she
looked like a boy I hung out with her
all the time I had this when I lived in
Santa Fe which we were gonna talk about
I lived in Santa Fe I was bartending at
this place called the cowgirl
did you go there you definitely did it
was it's the spot so I was bartending
there and it's funny because that you
know they have all these different
celebrities that have houses there or
they're in town filming stuff because
the tax write-off for movies in New
Mexico and so I used to wait or I used
to bartend for Sam Shepard drover Sam
Shepard so he would come in and one day
and like we always what's-her-name so
beautiful just oh that's so gorgeous
she's an American Horror Story jealous
of Sam sure just absolutely bound
jealous of Sam [ __ ] he's dead now you
can always jealous of him money you can
get her now his wife what the hell is
her name stunning
Marilyn Reno I don't think they were
married Jessica Lange yes so beautiful
talk about aging well I mean that dog
hot right now smile Always Rings Twice
listen titties to her knees and we still
want to play with them don't see well
I'm just saying she's the oldest
shepherd you see what Jess you seen a
little I didn't see her she was amazing
in I've seen her in um American Horror
Story she's gorgeous but so Sam would
come in and uh one day I got off early
and we were having a margarita together
this is back when I drank and uh I had
this best friend who looked like a boy
which was a lesbian just such a less and
I don't know what we were talking about
we're talking about like I was like oh I
want to do comedy I want to move to New
York I want to you know and he was like
comedy so scary and I was like yeah I
just want to live like an extraordinary
life he goes you are living an
extraordinary life you're gay right I
was like no I'm not gay
so he thought I was a lesbian cuz this
girl all the time I was gonna make I was
gonna make shirts that said Sam Shepard
think I'm gay thinks I'm gay and he was
gonna he was like I want 10% we had this
whole thing and then years later I moved
to I moved to New York and I was working
at this restaurant in Alphabet City and
Sam Shepard walked by me and I'm like oh
my god Sam I did it I moved to New York
I I'm doing stand-up and he goes did
this used to be a jazz club I was like
god dammit no memory of who I was just
like an RA [ __ ] but um it was really
funny but anyway so that girl I'd like
hung out with her all the time we worked
at the same restaurant together I was
drinking a lot and she just planted
those seeds you know she was like do you
think you're gay and I was like I don't
she's like do you think maybe the reason
that you don't think your guy is because
you're gay and I was like huh she like
Jedi Mind tricked me a little bit and I
was like I don't know maybe it's
homophobia that I never considered being
a lesbian but I've been boy crazy since
I was a little like really little always
boy how does you finger you well she oh
my god please first of all last night
anyway ladies I heard you and then and
then he told like three different
stories I'm like I know just like I
wanna oh my god Lee put your boner away
for once you know but I'm sorry alright
so um so then we were like you know we
would just drink late and I was dating a
bartender at a bar a couple things down
and he was like kind of like he was like
a bro and I don't know she just he
showed me we were over there one day and
he was he showed us he brought us into
the office and he showed both of us two
girls one cup and she was like seemed
boys suck and I was like so then that
night we like we would make out we'd get
drunk and make out and then we went back
to her place and she fingered and I
swear I feel like she fingered
homophobia and to me like it just wasn't
I just was like this isn't right I just
like I don't want this finger I was like
this [ __ ] how many knuckles are in
there Jesus it's hot it was just like I
just wasn't into it I was like let's
just poke a newborn how long you live in
Santa Fe seven years and you loved it uh
I mean I would like how to develops with
quite a drinking problem okay hey quit
drinking right when every way as well -
there is - do this up a bit
there was nothing yeah there's nothing
it's like a retirement six
I was there your questions I only went
out that whatever the hop Club was swag
Adam had a party one night at aha I was
there I was go-go dancing at apartment I
was a go-go dancer at the one club swig
it doesn't exist anymore it was owned by
two gay guys who and it was kind of a
gay club but because there was it was
the only nightclub in Santa Fe and Santa
Fe is such a small town everyone just
went so they had three podiums and it
was originally this gay guy mean like a
little twink me and then this like
crossdresser trans transvestite Brandi
who was Calvin during the day and Brandi
at night and then they fired the boy and
then it was a stripper me and this and
people come up to me like do you have
duct tape too because Brandi would have
duck duct tape there dick and so they
come up to me and I was like I mean I'm
not even really a good dancer I was I
would be hammered crying people I didn't
like when people touched me or tipped I
would get mad when they were like I'm
like you're objectifying me like this is
your job but it was fifty bucks an hour
plus tips and I would just wear like a
[ __ ] little outfit and just dance up
there get so hammered just falling off I
would fall down all the time I was
crying fake eyelashes stuck to my cheek
I had those chicken cutlets like the
little like boob things and I would
sweat and they would slide up and people
like your thing showing like I was a
Maui you cry you don't like it I just
was like yeah I don't know a mess yeah
and I was a I was a nanny by day and so
I would go my knees we're all sore
bending down from dancing so I would
like have to bend down to hang out with
these kids that have glitter all over my
face it was ridiculous have like two
hours of sleep I was an innkeeper I had
to quit that job or I guess I got fired
but I showed up wasted for my morning
shift I said John no comment
there's no comedy I mean that knife is
zero if there's six weeks and I went to
the bar around the corner from the Santa
Fe like a redneck type bar the cowgirl
because I came at lectures girlfriend
should the cowgirl yeah Heather I
bartender with her yeah and I used to go
to one hour Berto crane how did you
Jitsu plays huh Alberto crane is not
here okay he's got one of the biggest
schools Burbank and Glendale all right I
met him in Santa Fe New Mexico his first
you Judas it's unbelievable
welltake got me sober tape I used to
wait on him at the cowgirl and he was
annoying his chick as they come in also
not like ordering drinks and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] no [ __ ] sales you know but I
mean they would tip on top but they were
always like special needs and annoying
but Tate I might have talked about this
on Rogen but Tate he put together on the
karaoke night he knew I wanted to do
stand-up so he put together like a
situation where I could go up during
karaoke night and do stand-up so I did
my first show he put that on for me then
when I moved to New York and I realize I
had to quit drinking I called him and he
helped me get sober and so it's a good
[ __ ] yeah and then I came out here I
didn't even know he was like connected
to comedy in any way [ __ ] yeah he's
pretty yeah he's like one of my best
friends for almost funny he was an extra
long issue yeah I've watched his ascend
and it's you see you know issues I'm
like Sebastian yeah it was 36 and
Sebastian was a kid and he was a waiter
and you tried on MTV and you see
Sebastian and if you really like
Sebastian like Ave you guys the friends
at the store you get this twinkle in
your heart you like wow that's that's
amazing yeah and it lets it convinces
you that this is a life yeah that I'm
like a child tell these young guys this
is a life this is a great life it's just
a journey it's the number one I still
remember nobody's all over Sebastian was
but he had one fan the club owner in
Dallas who kept telling everybody who
came to listen the next great thing of
Sebastian yeah I'm telling me saying
I've had him in here for the last two
new years because he's like dice like
yeah in Texas they really like that and
when you see Sebastian you know now will
you see the people who are in the
conveyer belt who are on their way up
they don't know if they think they're
struggling I didn't get that role
one in four times four produces you're
on the good what you get in eleven forty
five spots at the school yeah and you
got a manager an age pay about this is a
heaven yet we're living on I can't
believe I like it's not a diff one I
wake up I'm like am I dreaming I can't
believe that it's like and I'm not like
financially I'm not killing it right now
but it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
doesn't [ __ ] matter people have no
idea like I always say to myself this
every like three or four days when I'm
writing in the morning I stop and I go
what was that doing ten years today
and I forced my mind to go where I was
let's go one deeper yeah October of 99
I had New Year's in El Paso for 2002
cake the world was gonna end
oh yeah I had a Houston going up to it
new years ago and I had a triplet or
plan my big thing and that was a regular
yeah I'll get six lots of weeks [ __ ]
best uh and I was planning a tour I
didn't think I was up to par in LA like
I was getting spot to the store but when
I would go to the improv and get
sandwiched in between like Patton Oswalt
I would always like soos what's that
word for leather like a fish I would
yeah I just looked at myself I'm
probably gonna hit asses yeah gave me
something I took it myself objectively
and I said you know what
it's time to go on a training run yeah
and I left December 20th of 99 I came
back in like May I got a six-month
that's so fun like the first three weeks
were bought yeah everything else and
then you just went for it
just who's got an opening yeah call the
funny bones listen I'm on the road
whatever MC yeah you really just have to
make that rough that's all it is just
like the big in 304 in a condo on the
condo you eating Subway sandwiches
tunnels you exercise a little
but you watch TV in your right you buy a
bag of dope that's your big game party
for the week you buy a send me the bag
of dope that last yeah you smoke
everything you smoke it down your finger
yeah look at your finger you're an open
mic oh they're brown yeah you know
everything you do is to the extreme when
you get a sandwich you got it as a
resident head you know those people that
say let's go try that I ain't tryin
nothin that Chinese lunch special gives
you a super salad of the bowl of rice a
feather for 695 that was going yeah but
let's try the Hindu I don't want to try
nothin you don't even take a chance okay
don't even take a chance
well you gotta go you got 20 the house
to last you for the day yeah that
meatball sandwich is eight million is
huge it gives you a little bit of
heartburn but half of it for lunch yeah
it's two million you know that's how you
look at things you start looking at
things like that and you just when I got
here nobody was talking to me like no
Montreal I had no comedy agent I was an
agency called the coloring book
how hilarious and you had to make your
resume different colors are you making
that up
no Charlie Chan printing I don't have to
give her a hundred resumes every two
weeks could in those days you got sent
out I would have to give her like a
hundred resumes what's your resume Joey
Diaz sag-aftra five-foot-ten 262 to 90
range forty to fifty BASEketball
Bronx County yeah comedy store improv
some fake play house yeah some fake
acting coach and swimming kids they were
there it interest you always have to put
swimming number one it has two directors
wanna know if you could swim all right
there you go you learn something
well it says interest on the bottom you
have to put swimming number one native
swimming knitting next just know that
learning swimming martial arts uh-huh a
language Oh
your accents make it up then that comes
that I didn't get the job in the New
York no no no no you're gonna write on
the bottom whatever's gonna get you into
the job but it's gonna be variable up
blade only like you're gonna speak
you're gonna say yesh and then I'm gonna
call ya I'm gonna fall in love with you
you'll never say a couple Yiddish words
in there but you're gonna iChat add a
chart and the end when you get to the
set they're gonna say we thought you
speculation you're gonna go yeah when I
was three I lived in Israel yeah not now
I forgot how do you speak Yiddish - not
Hollywood amel some lime wedge you said
here you could swim yeah [ __ ] Ambrose
well that was a kid I was the master
swimming program the 20 years ago my
shoulder broke ah but now what they
gonna do so rewrite the part for you I'm
saying so you know why about something I
told you this day my resume homily is no
friend it calmly is a girlfriend you got
a data you know kiss her neck bring her
fly it's the same thing with the resume
comedies the girlfriend the configure
male it's the only one yeah calmly is
your girlfriend so now you got to
[ __ ] your way into the rooms so you
got to write that in the bottom love I
do hate that feeling know when you're
like oh they're about to call me out on
this [ __ ] [ __ ] I just lied about I
tell the truth all the time like I put
heavy machine operator because I know
how to work a house yeah in college
whatever I know how to work a high-low
but you could you can stretch a lot you
can stretch okay let me give me an
example I had a dear friend who got
called in for Sons of Anarchy they
called me back and he goes at the
audition they asked me if I can ride a
motorcycle oh what'd you tell said he no
I hope you tell him yes no because I did
oh I know but he goes it was over 20
years ago I know good enough he got the
data set he was all worried he kept
calling me Joey you made me lie I'm in
trouble or no I didn't make you lie i
made you be blunt I made you be what's
that called
no there's a word where you you its
obscure
the answer is obscure you never give
somebody like February 12
you always go from the 12th to the 18th
you give him a big vague I know you gave
him a vague answer he didn't sleep the
night before you told me that how that's
gonna quit I feel that he [ __ ] what
he told me the truth does that no
worries they're gonna pull you yeah
you're not gonna be on the phone we
can't afford that they can't afford that
they have guys yeah you watch sons an
again they go by yeah you see that way
not one of them yeah Tate Fletcher is
actually every person yeah they're
always so you don't have to really okay
it'd be nice of you to pop a wheelie if
you can pop a wheelie but this time it
would be Massa they'd be upset because
they don't want you to get hurt right
there's some auditions where they'd go
listen we want to ask you like there was
an audition I went on where I swear to
god you did it head to the commercial
where now again oh that's fun in the
water was in the water oh that's fun the
audition I really can I have the [ __ ]
okay you had a sign a wave when you
wanted to let you know that you were
gonna work with the earth with the thing
yeah I got like me sighs that I'm not
taking that job I'm not that [ __ ] to
take a scale job with an alligator what
I'm gonna put yes sir I'm a play with
you yes I'm gonna let the casting
director fall along yeah I wanted to
late yeah it wasn't for somebody else
and I was happy I never saw a commercial
again I doubt they shot it
I thought they shot it because at the
end of the day they're gonna put you in
the water up to your neck with a widow
and there's like a cage that people
couldn't see and the alligator it was
gonna be talking next to you oh oh I
love that I'm an adrenaline junkie
though oh you know I love something like
I mean I listen at the end of the day I
think I would do it yeah it's gonna be a
trained animal and fun they said eight
you say they do whatever you know it's
definitely gonna bite you you know it's
not you never know they have it set up
they don't want you to get bitten like
think about you know Tom Cruise always
does his own stunts that must have no
way of them so much we're like Tom can
we just have someone that's like trained
to [ __ ] do let's do this we have to
deal with you it's like so much extra
you have to be you know it's like you
have extra insurance and all that stuff
nobody you they're not gonna want you to
get hurt
yeah but who are those Tiger trainers in
like Vegas oh the guy that got it yeah
nice on Tigers yeah I mean it could
happen but that's what's fun about it
that's fun no LIF did you have you been
skydiving no it's boring I would just go
straight to the earth I can't come to
Rumble destroy some fun and I can't get
them to run the Popeye's Chicken Nature
just run in front of runs back half 100
hours when people waiting there for the
spicy chicken just run naked right
there's a number now that's his first
job we'll give you 10,000 your first job
you got already is when I was naked
fifty an hour I got 50 an hour for 12
second job yep they have camera phones
Banyon but nobody's running every you're
gonna run so fast does he get to wear a
bag also a chubby guy comes running by
naked you just let me just say there's
gonna be kids in that line and he's
gonna get induced no he won't because by
the time they catch on listen nobody
will chase a fat chubby nobody wants to
even touch it
that sounds like me in college oh just a
lot of other guys have you seen it you
see an arm tackle that's what really a
chubby guy you go to tackle me your arms
gonna slip right off with it Greece
nobody wants to chase her homeless car
dirty oh you're gonna talk to you about
like that no way man nobody I Jason
naked man it's like we're talking last
night what's the one of the chances of
being a pedophile with a voice box right
that would be a good pedophile if I was
like if I had voice box
I'd never be a pedophile cuz you
tremendous a little kid come here oh I
thought you were saying cuz you had like
the little hole they could put their
dicks in well that's
smaller yeah come on in the 70s dad the
whole with a little curtain it's like a
peep show priest put his little kids
dick come to Papi's throat oh that's
disgusting it is disgusting
Merry Christmas what did you get into
car I have to all this I mean I know you
got some deep [ __ ] later on which is
really nobody's business for right now
but how long did you want to do comedy
for how long was it burning you up I was
uh I always made my dad laugh so it was
always like a thing where I was always
just trying to make my dad laughs my
whole life so I kind of started to
realize that I had like I just talked
[ __ ] like nobody I wasn't raised with
like boundaries or rules really so I
just always talk [ __ ] I just always said
whatever I think all the time and I
started to realize like I could kind of
affect the room by doing that and so
then in probably around college I was
like oh I think I get like do stand-up I
think I do that as a thing I want to do
that so then I was living in New Mexico
obviously there was no stand-up I was
just drinking a bunch and I just was
like I want to do it and then when The
Longest Yard came in I'm at like Nick
Swardson and Adam Sandler and people
like that and once I could see it you
know the arrogance of someone who starts
comedy when you just see it like oh I
could do that
like I just being able to see them in
real life and see like their actual size
that they're not like as big as I see
the monster yep and somewhat regularly
yes like you well I thought he's very
polite and very nice he was really
really sweet and I was just so he was
one of the first celebrities I'd met so
was I was so surprised at how little he
was enough that he's a little person but
like just compared to what I was used to
seeing him I was used to seeing him on
big screens it was deer I when I was
growing up in Boston like I would get
starstruck for people on the news hmm
like there was no internet back then so
like they were like oh everyone with
them everyone on TV was like exciting
and I wonder if it's different now well
it's rare that I get starstruck now
because I think what we do is the
[ __ ] coolest thing I think like what
we do is the night
thing so you know I have a lot of
respect for people and I you know and
there's celebrities that I get excited
to see but I don't get like start I got
like starstruck over like I saw I met
Jeff Probst the host of Survivor and I
love Survivor I got really [ __ ]
starstruck a friend it was embarrassing
I mean I got I got weird like I was like
I have to talk to you about this season
like I got really weird and like I just
got normal with Pauly like people that
were have been in my life since I was a
kid usually I'll get starstruck over so
if I see like Pauly Shore like someone I
don't get starstruck
I get more like I can't believe that I
still remember MTV had a show called
comedy kamikaze it was on the afternoons
at 4:30
I still remember saying Nick DiPaolo
Alicia Michaels Pauly Shore this Playa
you know on MTV when Pauly Shore pretty
much ran and yeah and now I got Pauly's
number yeah I know it's Wild Rose I am
like its I used to date this girl about
Dave Chappelle on stage it's like what's
my life what wouldn't sing the [ __ ] is
that I can have you know what I realized
- it's about like you have to adjust
your drew like your goals because you
can I just realized I get I've gotten
literally everything I want I had a very
like troubled childhood and then I'm now
in this place where it's like I've
gotten I can't believe it you were
saying about where was I tenors before
where was I 20 years before it's like
holy [ __ ] it's really I would be like
yeah I would have gotten more
traumatized as a kid if I never have a
[ __ ] Netflix special I've been like I
need more bad things I mean it's like I
can't believe - all worth it
it's every everything that has ever
happened in my life is absolutely worth
it because at this time so now it's like
adjusting and being like ask for more
you know you got to do the work and
stuff but it's like like believe that
you can have the things that you want
when you like meet these people it's
like I [ __ ] idolized your ass it's
weird when you like for me I don't know
I've never really been sorry I remember
seeing Richard Gere at the time I wanted
to beat him up
from 1979 to 82 I want to Jack Richard
yeah because every woman you talk to
like Richard yeah I took the girl to the
movies one time Richard you get showed
his ass you know I just dropped $30 for
nothing yeah good night Richard Gere
show his ass American Gigolo he do like
upside-down headstand every woman the
movie did away and that was it you were
done well I saw Richard Gere that wasn't
nobody really do I get James Coburn when
I first moved here me and Joe Rogan
chase James Coburn in the car on Sunset
and he had an Acura NSX but then I got
to work with him twice and the
starstruck one away yeah it goes away I
get sentimental I get sentimental like I
got a giant call from there from next
watson's I need feel do one line in my
movie but for some reason I got stuck
doing that one line with Don Johnson mmm
you have no idea with Don Johnson mentum
yeah love he was Miami Vice people
didn't do anything from on Friday nights
from 9:00 and 10:00 yeah to watch Don
Johnson he was the [ __ ] and to talk to
him now that he's grounded and at that
time he had just had a kid and he was
old and I felt like saying aren't you a
selfish bastard
yeah I'm looking 3 years later I think
now a wife up yeah 50 and I was like
thank God I didn't call bud Johnson
house well now his daughters and uh
fifty Shades of Grey he believed that
that's so embarrassing
yeah that's that's just tremendous like
that's you know it there's so many
people that you can't watch your
daughter's movie she's getting whipped
with a dick the entire movie you could
be proud of her he still has to be proud
of horses she's a cute kid she's
beautiful she's a cute beautiful she's a
great kid she's a cute kid
no there's so many people that I'm not I
don't get starstruck it doesn't really I
mean I get it motivates me to see ya
when you get motivated like a few
especially they go onstage and kill ya
but you know uh I saw what's the name at
the improv
and I didn't even know was her and I
tapped 20 years ago I would have been
soda starstruck the girl that used to be
married to Richie Sambora and and Tommy
leak that poor girl that she they pull
it through hell no Pamela Anderson no oh
I asked the coach she was America's you
know say yeah dessert they get her piece
she married two guys like a potato she's
got her braces you got all [ __ ] every
hooked on every pill they were hooked on
yes she was a lot of DUI
yeah well have you eyes you know it was
like a poison she let these Momo's in
her life you know this is a weird place
here so how long did it take how long
did you live in New York bouncing around
um
I moved to New York I I was living in
New Mexico and I was just drinking
really bad and I crashed my scooter
really bad and woke up with my face
split open and just like really really
bad so I knew I needed a change so I
decided to move because I was afraid of
drinking and driving I was afraid to
move to LA because I knew I'd have to
drive so I moved to New York to do
stand-up and then I start I was there
for like a month and a half and then I
finally went to an open mic and then
after my first open mic I quit drinking
and started just going to Mike's every
day and I started doing like five mics a
day and just like never stopped just
went as hard as possible immediately and
and then I got Montreal like two years
in really fast and bombed really bad
I'll say everyone except one person
bombed in my group but nobody really
talks about the bombing
I'll always admit my bombs but eight it
was so painful but then through that I
ended up getting I remember it's I had
there was this lawyer there that when he
goes don't worry you have a good look
and I was like what are you talking
about a good look he's like you have a
good look you'll be fine I'm like you
mean I work I work hard on my jokes like
I'm a comic I just didn't understand
like the Hollywood side of things at all
and then I ended up doing I met some
Booker's there and I started doing like
Chelsea Lately and stuff so that I was
coming out to LA all the time and like
living in my car but doing TV you know
and then
moved out here in 2013 got past at the
store right away only auditioned ones
thank you and then Tommy Tommy let me
ask you something before we move any
further your performance in Montreal
were you prepared unprepared
an experience for what you were gonna
walk into not ready for what you a
little walk into what you tagged it to I
would say it's a little bit of all the
things so I the Booker had said to me
after my I auditioned my first or there
was three years in but audition like my
first or second year I auditioned and
they were like we really like you you're
very new these are the things we want
you to work on so then that year I
worked on everything they told me and
then when they came back I was like way
better I mean I just didn't I just
everyone was mad at me I didn't stay for
any one sets I just did five sets a
night I worked during the day I just
this was always going to be my job so it
was just never I was there were no
distractions it was only comedy so then
when I came back I did really well on my
auditions and the Booker said do you
want to go this year or do you want
another year and I said I want it this
year I'm gonna kill I'm gonna be awesome
my mom's but I I'm okay with that I mean
it all worked out I think I've gotten
everything that I that I need and I want
at the right time even though I didn't
realize it at the time you know like
that it these were experiences it was
really it was a very it's a very very go
to Montreal course it's and if light and
I applaud you because after the bombing
most people were tapped out because they
would have thought that life as oh wow I
gotta go back and face these people so
here's what I know
I knew because I you know III have a you
know a strong sense of injustice you
know like I'll battle the battles I
don't care being the loud one that gets
in trouble or whatever if I see
something that needs to be addressed
when we went to Montreal
I did the unwrapped so there was the
repped the repped new faces and then
there was the unwrapped new faces which
was like a newer thing that we're doing
with people that didn't have agents or
managers now I had managers and agents
that wanted to sign me but the Booker
was like don't sign with him I want to
send you on rep so at this point I was
like [ __ ] if you don't give me
this [ __ ] thing you got in the
way of my work
like you got in the way of me making
money and stuff like that so then when I
did get it I went you know I was
confident in this seven minutes that I
had or whatever six minutes that I had
and we get there the show was ran two
hours late it was all industry in the
back talking there was no it was a very
it was a near impossible place to
succeed and and I know there's you can't
blame the audience for everything but it
was it was a rough situation and then
one kid killed Joe Mackey destroyed he
just destroyed and so then all of us
were like I guess we can't blame the
[ __ ] room but it was just a lot of
pressure there was um you know like all
these networks trying I just didn't know
I just had no clue about that all I know
is jokes I just knew you do jokes over
and over and over again until you get
them right there you just keep going
someone that's all I know
so the Hollywood side of it was very
confusing and it was like which is no
good field yeah there's no reason for it
okay I don't like it I don't like it
that's too much pressure to already
pressure situation I want you open my
career for you to have a day job yeah go
out at night learn what is it that's to
sleep on for hours and then go back to
that day job you know you do you two or
three Mike's but then you and your
friends get together for coffee yeah
talk [ __ ] yeah in the morning yeah even
though you gotta go to work at 7:00
sorry yeah we had an open mic at bloody
Jackson New York that we would go to
that was like would run till like 3:00
we'd be sleeping in the back just I mean
I I just it it always there were these
comments that would give me [ __ ] you
know like in their female comics that
started around the same time and they
that would give me [ __ ] about not
staying for their sets and stuff and I'm
like I don't know you I don't owe you
anything I'm not here for like a I have
my camaraderie with the people that work
as hard as me like my crew is the people
that bust their asses as hard as me I
don't have time for why would I be
staying for you you don't stay for me I
don't notice who's in the room when I'm
on this is about my work and then those
same girls spread rumors that I hooked
up with the Booker of Montreal to get in
or I'm like no I worked harder than you
it's like it's just all of those girls
don't they don't
in my world anymore they don't do it
it's like there's a you're just you just
have it or you don't that Drive this
tools in the beginning there's the
people who just talk and they get so
involved in the world that come in that
they missed the whole point again yeah
on it and finally the world the company
talks about don't come it talks about if
they get so caught up and this and that
and they talked themselves out of Tom
unless people like you were not it I
didn't give a [ __ ] no I think you were
[ __ ] I look at I look at you Whitney
Nikki Ally you all have [ __ ] jessimae
Peluso
y'all have one trait that at one point
you said [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] this
[ __ ] we're doing it our way a huge
respect you Whitney said something to me
once that she does you have two choices
as a woman in LA
you could calm your hair or go Sun dink
or put your hair up with a hat and go be
one of the boys and banging out with
them in there and earn their respect how
do you earn their respect not my suck on
that dick hmm by being there with never
to play in the morning knocking it out
of the park and I'm going Thank You Ali
yeah you call them and saying hey listen
Joey it's disrespectful
I show you a headlining Club 48th and
Tacoma do you mind if I Drive you for a
five-minute segment yeah that's a woman
deal sometimes that's what guys have to
do with it yeah that's part of it you
know
listen funny doesn't [ __ ] gender the
hard work it's just working like that's
what's so and it's just I was so careful
to not [ __ ] people in the beginning and
then it was so hilarious because they
ended up spreading rumors that I [ __ ]
people I'm like Jesus Christ like
there's just it's just a weird thing a
stigma that they put on chicks but I
don't give a [ __ ] it's I was talking to
Rogen about it he's like must have been
good if they said that about you must
have been good I was like I was [ __ ]
good and it's just like you know I
started stuff to learn but it's you know
if you're sitting around and you're
gossiping and you're thinking about why
if you look at someone who got something
and you go wow the reason they got that
is they must have had some privilege I
didn't have like
some of us to try to [ __ ] them or there
must've been some thing what you're
missing is that right now you're
supposed to be writing jokes like head
down write jokes work on your [ __ ] why
the [ __ ] are you paying attention to
other people have if someone has
something that you want and you have
that tang of jealousy think about what
are they doing that I'm not doing what
is it that like I could be doing that
this person is doing Ali Wong I used to
do open mics with her in New York this
[ __ ] would show up with a [ __ ]
camera
she had a goddamn GoPro or something she
would set up her camera she would come
in she would somehow get on the list
early so she could go like she just you
just worked the [ __ ] system there's
no like and she wasn't rude or anything
it's she was working hard and she would
come in with new jokes crushing her it's
like there's the reason that some of us
are at the store and some of us aren't
it's like right your jokes what are you
[ __ ] talking about you're blaming
another thing outside yourself it's you
[ __ ] I have got a huge sense of respect
for you ladies because I know what it's
like I've been now I know what it's like
I know it's been like to been taken and
I know what you need my mother well I
see you guys I see my mom in a bookie
office I see six guys and an office she
Alvin scream yeah and my mom right there
on the phone yeah I'm gonna pick up that
[ __ ] phone
that's money in the register yeah that
guy's a sucker and going and looking at
her going most women can handle this job
well it's just like he's in the room
with this many men it takes a certain
woman that's why I bring her yeah that's
why we do a podcast I want to include I
wish I lived in Jersey but I take it to
a social club yeah becomes the more walk
into a room with men and reading men
remanded from an early age
who's gonna mess with me who's not mad
at me coming to me going daddy I don't
like that guy yeah I don't know I just
don't like how he looks at me they see
that [ __ ] right they see stuff we don't
see when yeah so it's I have a huge a
couple years ago it was the paint but
somebody said women weren't funny like
then the guy lost his job stuff and I
know you know I don't know him well and
so this day it's always bothered me that
comment because who was the first person
you watched on TV that made you laugh
Lucille Ball we grew up on Lucille Ball
so for you to make that statement and
cowboy that I'm just like listen I am a
girl and I've been funny my whole
[ __ ] time with me all day and I'm
laughing the entire time so I don't you
know it's like hey you can't I don't
know what to say to these people but
it's it's it's not like a real comment
even I don't even really I don't know it
bothered me because it was a dumb
comment but without thought like you
have your opinion everybody has their
opinion but thought to that opinion I
grew up on Lucille Ball so maybe I don't
like a lot of it like I hear gripes all
the [ __ ] time I'm not involved in the
Comedy Store in the comedy world gossip
car yeah because my have my own family
doing things when I hear things I go
really like I don't know I don't know I
hear little thing you know I leave the
Comedy Store at 10:15 before the
darkness comes out oh my god I'm there
till like 3:00 in the morning I'm like
holding it down oh I have listen I used
to be there when I used to Brody was my
barometer because Brody Woodley I'd be
like oh [ __ ] - Brody leave before me I
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
did Brody leave before me so now I just
have to be like oh [ __ ] once they like
lock the one door and you got to go
through the kitchen on my Gullu I've
stayed too long I'm like [ __ ] Madan
Barris in the back oh yeah we it's just
so fun I mean it's just a completely
different life it is just goddamn
goodbye it's a completely different life
down there I love it that I know all the
wagers darling I know everyone's fine
this is my home I was talking to there's
this girl that I that um that I had had
a falling-out with a bull she had a
falling-out with man a grown woman I
don't have falling outs with people but
um I was kind of trying to like talk to
her like hey do you want to like bury
the hatchet or whatever and and she was
like no and I was like I just want to
let you know like this is my house and
it's never gonna be weird for me so I
will always treat you with like love and
respect because this is my home and
that's what I do to people my home but
like just know that they will never be
nothing weird will ever be coming from
me because this is the most important
this is
space that's how I feel at the Comedy
Store him you know I went to New York
this shoot is a problem movie and that
was the first time I was away from here
for three days and it was weird
it was a tough three weeks for me
because it got me thinking III got the
seal on my friends I grew up with I'm
tight with my friends they grew up
without my family so I got the see lots
of them in groups or an individual
situations and I started thinking about
my life here and I'm like man my life is
kind of weird I don't have that and uh
November 12th this year I really
realized that didn't have that it took
me [ __ ] slipping in the Comedy Store
yeah analyze that the next today is the
overwhelming support that I had yeah he
was all the [ __ ] whelming well half
of it was them trying not to get yeah
not to sue them ya know Whitney did you
hear what I said to wit me yeah it's
like because Whitney so codependent I go
Whitney I'm so sorry you're going to so
Joey fell and he hurt his knee in the
kitchen hamstring his hamstring and in
the kitchen and he's still he's like up
on a chair a roller chair with his leg
up and Whitney's like by him and I can
just see I just know her you know it's
like Oh Whitney I'm so sorry you're
going through this so empathetic she's
uh it was a lot of people waitresses and
I got calls the next day I would never
sue the calorie store but I went home
and in my pain leg with the ice on yeah
it's like that's my own
yeah it's family that's smile you know
you know when you walk up to the belly
room there's that picture of Brody's oh
yeah you just touch kiss that [ __ ]
every time it's it's home it's something
that I'm in the Mafia yeah
I'm in a different mafia and it's so
weird how people go when you're in the
Mafia if your kid is in the hospital on
his deathbed and the boss calls and you
gotta leave your kid that's never gonna
happen that's a dumb statement man I
feel the same way with the Commish
like that's my family there's conveniens
then there's the regulars at the Commons
my mind we breathe to one another you
know I like the Comedy Store now because
there's really no bad blood among I can
look you in the eye and tell you that do
people get on your last nerve that's
gonna happen at the dentist office
that's gonna happen Robb's there's
people that'll light there but there's
no beefs no I can't even you know what
I'm saying that wrong I love the staff
there I love the management there and I
love all the comedians it's amazing
there's a couple little [ __ ]
producers that think this yeah they're
annoying but beside that man I got a
hole yeah no I got a hole I got I love
performing man it's amazing I don't give
a [ __ ] when I have a fault oh it's no no
it's not give a [ __ ] right now always
have our bat like just yeah I don't give
a [ __ ] when I perform I really know yeah
when I go up there it's to kill yeah
I'll give a [ __ ] what hurt you what
doesn't hurt you what your mother thinks
what religion you are yeah I go down you
know ever since Mitzi died it drove me
crazy
yeah like when Mitzi sure died I'm not
the type to cry yeah I don't have to go
to the wrist I don't have to go to Holly
man Bryan Shaw everybody it just made me
Stu but somebody dies I just do yeah I
just do I take something out of their
death some it see it was bringing the
basses back I just ate a bag of dicks on
Netflix hmm with Christine that was yeah
the door fell down during her set and
then I went up there and I was [ __ ]
rattled and on the plane and a couple
days later Mitch he died or whatever and
it all came together what my plan was
yeah how much I had drifted like I'm a
Mitzi shore soldier yeah you know that
uh the black drill sergeant an officer
in the gentleman uh-huh you a drill
sergeant all your life but she sure was
a drill sergeant and if you listen to
her you would get some way yeah and that
was the main thing was do you think yeah
yeah they would already got the [ __ ]
money well they also don't here's the
thing nobody wants like nobody has time
for your like low self-esteem or your
like the whole audience just wants you
to be yourself
to be yourself they just want no gold
they're there to watch you and if
they're not get the [ __ ] out I had some
girl I made a joke the people that were
leaving I got one on late night and a
bunch of people were leaving and I said
if you leave during my set you raped me
just heads up you'll never work again
and this woman goes I was raped don't
say I go [ __ ] everyone on the stage was
raped or molested shut the [ __ ] up I was
like you should have a better job if
your rapes like why are you in the
audience like I just was like I was boom
boom bah like what the [ __ ] was in are
you you shouldn't come out if that
really affects you like you should be in
your house being a victim are you fine
now [ __ ] how are you now are you being
raped now are we living it just like
grow up [ __ ] it's like who the [ __ ]
wasn't raped
we shot you gotta be kidding me we lived
in a town of [ __ ] the victims uh how
long did it take you before used to tell
you how long did you stay in New York
till 2013 you come on 2013 come out here
come a regular at the store come become
a regular at the store and then you know
I'm going on real late and then and I
was in a relationship that I was not
happy in and I was immediately he was a
rollerblader
he was i imagining you on rollerblades
actually naked as chair blading in front
of the it's worse than just the chicken
line
no it was like a younger kid I was like
pang is right it was a weird thing a
good lesson a three-year lesson but um I
was I didn't feel like self expressed in
that and I didn't feel like I could
really like talk about what I was going
through because I hated my boyfriend so
much she was such a nice guy but I just
didn't I was just unhappy so I was it
was like three years of feeling like I
did and I had a TV show on E at that
time so I was doing that for like four
episodes they gave me a talk show and so
I was like kind of distracted by that
but the stand-up just wasn't and I felt
so too part like I had this underlying
depression because I didn't feel self
expressed on stage and then broke up
with him moved back to New York for a
year and then I was like I gotta go back
to LA I started working on Sacha Baron
Cohen show on who is America so I moved
out back for that and then I was like
I'm never leaving here I'm at The Comedy
Store why do I [ __ ] leave the Comedy
Store and then I just started really not
giving a [ __ ] and you know what's in
your body language it's and everything
you do now you book like girl code
I used to do girl code yeah how is that
all these very [ __ ] came it was so
easy well you know Jessie and I didn't
listen Jesse Jesse and I didn't they
didn't wouldn't put us on the show
together like they thought were the
sandwich
I don't think Jesse and I are alike I
mean we're like white trash in a fun way
but I don't think we're actually that
much alike I think we have different we
get along really well but I just don't
think we're the same type but they so
she got cast originally they were coming
to see me all the time and then they
cast her I guess in the role of the
blonde chick and then she ended up
there's something with EE or something
and so then they ended up having me on
so Jesse and I never got to be on
together
Veigar twice she's sitting on a gold
mine oh my god was she driving her
walking so was it by another Asian woman
I don't know the first one was it was it
was Asian on Asia Natasha she got hit
twice they're trying to hurt you at this
point they're aiming for you [ __ ] have
you got it twice okay when you're
walking or the other night economists
might door guys bias you could hear the
door it it just I would have been dead
because it takes it off the hinges it
just hits you oh you just when you're
stepping out of your car yeah you know
that's on you I got in a car accident
where a girl opened her cards my and
she's liable it's all you you have to
make sure that there's no car you would
have been at fault what happened years
ago somebody I was headed to an airport
and somebody we pulled over and somebody
hit it with a bike I don't know it
happened so long ago wasn't my wife is
driving to the yeah yeah yeah which has
to well yeah we used to leave like 20
minutes before or step on it [ __ ] is
that how you are you always late for
things no I'm late for flights I like to
run I like to win God when chasing a
lover out here
before 9/11 I thought I was Johnny cute
and I would do that it's only gonna take
us a half out in the airport
and don't let me in yeah you know then
9/11 came that long then you mature as a
comic because when you're a feature
or you're a non important that liner you
know like you just headlining and you're
getting the basic scale they don't give
a [ __ ] of you show or not [ __ ] call
some other Jasmine yeah down the corner
I got a local and yeah they give him the
same the club owner well just in this
yeah yeah it's not like Tracy Morgan
yeah it's not like Joe Rogan coming to
town people excited who's in town asleep
I don't know some guy named John Schmidt
that's when you're that person I didn't
give a [ __ ] either I gotta give a [ __ ]
well then you start it's your mindset
you start thinking about that yeah you
start to get about these people I got
babysitter's yeah they want to see a
joke about you mug and a hooker and like
waiting on fire and you know you know
what let me get to the airport law
really yeah
what's the harm because it's two
different feelings it's being stressed
out the whole time she got on the plane
and you go right or you walk and you
know it's like the old expression you
could run down there and [ __ ] one of
them or walk down there [ __ ] wall Lee
and I were having this conversation last
night we live in Los Angeles he was
saying that andrew dice clay made tapes
two days ago for most lax that he had to
wait for an hour to get picked up
did you see there was a fire last night
at LAX at the bus station
uber people you know I was with you all
like last time I spoke to you as a
12-day don't even say that just to
constantly be interrogating me and we
did a bunch of other bulls and we did
some bad pills so I passed it on the
couch I don't even say that listed on
fire well I throw it on fire just like
that oh but racial strife the problem
you know the juubi comes out when I get
aggravated
so I this more that's welcome to mercy
we don't you know with wind plane wasn't
the word the buses on fire in LAX this
morning
that's you don't guess you don't care I
told you places show she's over there
she's up leveled spine whatever that
somebody lit two buses on fire I'd be
will be lot less night that's some
people were really pissed off last night
it does suck when you come back and
you're like waiting for a [ __ ] it and
you're like people and you order the
uber and then it's like eight minutes
yeah and then you're like wait a second
why isn't I'm moving wait where are you
going where the [ __ ] are you going and
then it's hours later and you're just
like so tired you just want to get home
you have no idea what like people have
no idea what it's like to go down to LA
accident how you feel that was telling
me yeah what to the point now where I'm
not gonna over I'm not doing that
forget it forget it I'm not taking a
limo down I'm not joy bananas I'm
letting the Mafia I'm not totally bro so
let's just do this let's just take the
first flight out and if it's at 6:00
a.m. that means I gotta be there at 5:00
I love getting up at 3:00 a.m. I would
just pull an all-nighter probably no I
can't trust myself to fall asleep and
wake up if I'm gonna sleep an hour late
on co-sleeper now are you gonna cancer
you spot at the [ __ ] store no way and
you're gonna go to bed at night and get
five hours sleep so you how the [ __ ] do
you go to bed at 9:00 what are you
taking
I'll give you a little something all
right I'm going about earlier tonight
you call me and we'll get you something
and you go to fell in line and you get
up in let's say the alarm
since after 2:00 3:00 you'll get it for
2:30 to give you an extra half hour to
drink your coffee and peace hmm right
your little log so on the Internet tell
somebody on Twitter look at their
mother's ass smells like Bayonne and
that they need a bidet from today from
Tucci you get in your car and you drive
down and you go to the airport at 4:30
you park right next to the elevator
yeah and you walk in you go through
clear cuz then I'm a felon they don't
give me that I think I gotta take my
shoes off they wanna smell my fungi so I
give it to him and you go in there and
you pray that somebody's open you know
like what
for my left boston legal seafood was
open [ __ ]
have a little morning lobster legal
seafood card oh sure I gotta get some
seafood [ __ ] yeah I got them all I got
legal see I'm gonna I'm gonna give
[ __ ] that's a roll with you and then
we're gonna go all this I got my little
credit cards but I got a thousand of
these I got I got about 21 of $22,000 on
Jersey Mike's oh my god you're fine
because I like the turkey and provolone
sandwich Jersey Mike's is good no come
on
turkey and provolone is good that said
everything else is box awesome oh man
nah the cheesesteak ain't bad listen but
she's thinking God would just you have
to adjust your expectations when you're
not in New Jersey you missed East Coast
I do miss the East Coast I'm excited to
go back for the holidays but I am very
happy here but I do like it's fund and
meet East Coast people here I got in a
fight with his chicken the audience in
the main room it was not the same chick
you know I got a PMS yeah well yeah
heckle me when I'm PMSing you're gonna
get a [ __ ]
but so I was like fighting with this
girl and it was fun I mean it was fun
you know when you like well you know
when you go too far but it feels good
when you lose it you're like oh god I
feel great it was like that you know and
afterwards I was like I Prai should've
lost my [ __ ] so much even though I ended
well and then everyone came up to me
afterwards and they're like that was
awesome I rose for some reason it was
like all East Coast people and the
audience so ever [ __ ] loved it they
were like so psyched you know now either
like chill don't why don't yell and in a
failure like we'll [ __ ] beat the [ __ ]
on this [ __ ] that's funny that your
accent doesn't tell me fully but
everything else about your body language
your attitude the way you move your
hands everything else is very Philly I
mean it comes back when I go home like
I'll come back from from Christmas
probably sounding pretty Philly over
every the eggs over there well you guys
for the future what are your plans for
2020 what do you want to do 2020 I'm
trying to go into 2020 with no beefs no
like cuz I honestly really
any ill-will towards people but I'm just
trying to like drop any sort of like
expectations maybe a people like trying
to forgive everyone and myself for all
my stuff just going really like clean I
want to go and clean to 20 20
did you mean work wise work wise yeah
rich and famous are you gonna get I
don't know what's this it's gonna happen
anyway I'm working on like I'm writing
some stuff it's just focusing on
stand-up and bringing some other stuff
on write a book I got I got plans you
know I really I don't know I just I'm
just happy I just think my set of all
yeah whenever I see you make me happy I
know you one of those people that it's
always a pleasure to see the other thing
was that night I felt I'm laying there
you even watch like a football player
when a play gets broken up and he lands
and he holds his knee and he holds his
head okay because the pain is so much
that you you have to control you
something like I'm surprised I didn't
pass out at the store that night like
right now my leg is healed except for
it's shot it feels like somebody shot me
in the ass with a needle hmm and they
did it like without training it's like a
little numb pain no pain yeah but that
night I was in pain and I was breathing
out of my nose I was focusing really
hard not good not to pass out and they
turned me around and you know Whitney
was talking with me and trying to get me
pain pills and figure out what it is and
asked me if I wanna go to the hospital
in the middle of all this anyway
Letterman looks me aim the [ __ ] iron
goes hey [ __ ]
no I don't care how much pain you are I
don't care if you diet if you're taking
your last breath you ask a man if he
wants a [ __ ] he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he has to think twice he could be
bleeding for me like didn't hurt anymore
you gonna be bleeding from your side and
you'll actually think about it can I
bleed and get a [ __ ] but this and I
looking at like you got a knock it off
another one nobody second might think
I'm an old man like I don't
it's a shame like I feel bad for a young
girl that would say it's a real
injustice they go that sperm was a
little chunkier
it was so slow 56 it's a different type
of I go penny knock it off and she goes
I wasn't gonna suck your dick I wasn't
yet one of these guys to suck your dick
let me tell you something I went from
being in pain and that's what people
understand when a guy like me like I
went to the same doctor for 22 years
because I'm scared of doctors but he
figured out how to soften me up by
telling me funny things the real genius
of charlie is changing how somebody
feels like I love it I don't love it
love somebody's paradise house yeah I
know what it feel as a parent but it's
such a morbid [ __ ] time in your life
it's so morbid that your inner respect
for a parent your mommy your dad doesn't
even want you like you're like how can I
even think of putting on Seinfeld in a
moment like yeah you know like your
inner but you're praying for joy to say
something yeah well I'll come up to you
hug yes I'm really sorry about your dad
I know how much you love them yeah it's
been a real blow in my family my mother
can't get over it
like a [ __ ] at least we're getting
that boat down there yet yeah you're
such a dirty boy yeah yeah yeah oh my
god don't make me laugh like with
something I would see is his please
don't make yeah please don't my friend
yeah did your job my best friend got a
cesarean section she was like you can
come over meet the baby but she's like
you can't make me laugh and I was like
it was the best man my [ __ ] I'm such a
[ __ ] she was like please stop please
stop please stop I just could I was like
don't you dare tell me not to make you
laugh I loved all that oh it was the
most fun I loved I loved like I still
have one particular than my friend had a
broken arm my friend was having a month
from [ __ ] hell we were 18 he went to
you know you know how you throw your car
at somebody like he threw the car at
some like he stepped like Uli's crossing
the streets of Italy yeah when Esther
coos going by in our
/ yeah and you stopped before you get
there
he went to stop you hit my friend my
friend threw a punch at him my buddy put
his arm up to block him he was so skinny
it broke his own oh my god that he was
having a month the hell oh so he's got a
broken arm he's got a girlfriend in high
school it's hard to try yeah she's
available to the highest bidder
everybody says she sucked a good dick
whatever you brother a ring you out
didn't ya so he bought her a TV and she
was at home she broke up with him he was
at home watch the TV with the guy he
kept calling her butthole called her a
[ __ ] yeah whoo and all this [ __ ] she
actually came up to the bar through a
[ __ ] beatin on him
in front of all of us honey we were all
kids she jumped out of the car and you
started smack on 182 Jersey hilarious
you ever call me a [ __ ] your mother's
off yeah he's getting beat up we pull
her off a put her in the car we take him
inside we sit out was sitting there he's
just staring at his being Angus I should
go down and take that [ __ ] to you and
next you know my buddy goes just look at
the bright side right now her and Louise
are probably watching that TV on there
popping his head up and just shaking it
you know a little laughing yeah like
that's you know you know what man that's
what it's for it's our gift and that
night was the night I went home I told
my wife were both [ __ ] laugh and I
said hey you up that life yeah thank you
yeah making me laugh it's such a
difficult it was a dick because I was
thinking about Miami man at two weeks so
I could not cancel yeah I couldn't
cancel like I would have to go up there
with stitches there's no Maggie what do
you have a wheelchair no I lied why did
it yeah I went home I did the right way
I said I did it from A to Z I ended up
an urgent care because it's wall tubing
I did the two days of pain pills I got
really but I got a steroid but then the
healing process has been acupuncture
cryotherapy Nova Thor massage made
ellenberger gave us a gun
your muscles so at night I'll even ask
my wife I just bust out my leg mas yeah
my stretch makes me stress that
hamstring yeah cuz I stretch I bust her
all the way down on my ankle and it's
like a [ __ ] machine gun that breaks
up well yeah I think I know every time I
hang my legs upside down I mean I've
worked on this yeah I gave it blood I've
been doing leg extensions and still go
to but diving kickboxing yeah Weiss in
ten days and nothing so far can you roll
or no no I'm not gonna roll at all at
all that's two if yeah it's yeah it's
gonna give us can that's it
hip escapes and passing the guard I
can't do that
definite and you know when somebody
slices through on the pass how long have
you been involved with you Jitsu I've
been doing it on and off for like a year
what do you think so far I love it it's
so fun and you love to noogie
it's yeah I dunno games just noogie so
yeah I mean I never tried D so I don't
know I can't there's nothing against
it's a lot of fun to this I mean I would
I would try although it's so fun I mean
I can't believe I'm like what the [ __ ]
was I doing exercising by myself and
like a jet that's so boring and you know
bike that day oh I know Dante yeah is he
a boy yeah that's my boy I saw him the
other night at the store it was a I sent
a picture to Scotty Epstein did you see
the video that uh that I made with the
I'll send it to you we made Scotty and I
made a video cuz he's got these giant we
called him Dante like there are these
big giant black dummies before I guess
striking or whatever so he put them out
back and we did a video where I was
pretending to blow them and he came back
to catch me he was like Dante and I
guess he was get back in class and I'm
blowing them in and I go don't tell my
dad don't tell my dad and then they like
pan over to the one black student it was
just like shaking his head no wasn't
Dante Dante hasn't been there in a sec
Dante if you're listening what the plug
no I called him he said he hurt his foot
he stepped in the other I call the VLA
check the bottom I know you gotta get
roommates and whatnot so yeah Dante's
family for 20 years
thought there's been family since 1997
yeah I still have been coming all my
house falling asleep with a bag of fish
he would go to rouse and
you go to routes you buy fish don't cut
up and fry it for you okay he would be
hammered you fall asleep and finning my
cat was traitor I would go in the bag
forget he woke up and say get this
[ __ ] cat out of my fish that
had been in the [ __ ] he was at first
in there yeah my greasy and everything
for we self-revealing like [ __ ] all
mr. cat it was busy is the whole [ __ ]
thing but Annie no I want to thank you
for saving my life that night you know
you guys you made me [ __ ] laugh you
definitely have a fan with me if you
ever need anything yeah oh yeah I'm a
fan man I love what you do I love how
you do it this I love you I feel kindred
to you I feel yes and I do want to be
more I want to I I got a I got to study
you a little bit cuz I do want to be
more I have so many [ __ ] crazy
stories and you know I'm going up and
I'm telling these jokes is up but
there's not like there's just like a lot
of untapped stuff so I really gotta like
I got to tap into that I'm younger you
had delinquent prom no yeah you had any
arrests they deliver I never got
arrested but I was like always running
for my life I really was like I would
always be like in Jersey City running
from a [ __ ] or so I mean it was like I
just have so many I should almost die it
a lot it was just a lot of really like
hanging out with really it wasn't I mean
I was drinking and stuff but it was just
my parents weren't watching me I just
was I was just out and and I ended up
going to a school for juvenile
delinquents because I had a good art
program and it's just like do not send
your kids to a [ __ ] school I mean I
was like smoking cigarettes in the
bathroom and public school but I wasn't
that bad you know and then I was with
all these young criminals and it was
just like I just forgot taken by them
but I always had like that kind of
Quaker
upbringing I was always like good you
know so it was it kept me from going too
far but it was a lot of like running
like running call the cops go likes sure
like that doesn't it it just is a lot
and I think that's why I'm such an
adrenaline junkie my things like
skydiving aren't fun cuz it's just like
I just was in I feel like I was like The
Jungle Book kid you know like I just was
like in the jungle Oh
and so now it's like nothing's really
surprises me that much or guys you a
personal question
are you looking for love at all of
course yeah really yeah well I think I
would have a kid I've done ayahuasca
four times in the past year and most of
the times it's like be like you should
have a kid so it's like about getting to
a place in my career where I'm I feel
happy and and good about it and then
hopefully finding a partner and someone
to like you know make a tribe weather or
something like that carry the lineage of
my people so I'm thinking about I don't
know but it's you know I have a lot to
work on I have some issues
oh you're very funny you're a beautiful
girl and you have a great career who do
I [ __ ] date who dates me who died
it's like who's the it's hard if I was
20 years younger looking and I could
keep up with you I try you you can say
if I give you a world but so much you're
a backbreaker
yeah it's a lot it's a lot I gotta find
the right person you're the real deal
you need a special you need an opposite
yeah you need the quiet guy that says
she's crazy what can I do you yeah need
to date the guy that's like Paulie and
goodfellas I talk to them all the time
they don't listen yeah it's hard Brian
essence and you know Brian Simpson with
me yeah he does late night he's so funny
he's really great you wouldn't see him
just cuz you leave but he is [ __ ]
hilarious he just did David Spade he did
stand-up on there but he he said to me
he goes you know your problem is you're
attracted to brilliance and it's true so
I end up but it's like I'm Braille you
so that I'm like what these other minds
and it's like we're all crazy I think
that comes with like beautiful minds
come with a lot of crazy [ __ ] always a
[ __ ] yeah it's about a certain man that
out ah a time you always have an open
door you I love you dearly bang fan and
you need anything you call I got you if
you ever need it if you need a [ __ ]
from a not from a kitchen wigger at the
Comedy Store you got no no that's what I
call them the kitchen wiggers look at
them now and look at how their kitchen
orders I don't want no [ __ ] nobody
understand my dick is no bueno
all right guys It's A Wrap enjoy any
dates you want to promote you at the
room I'm not sure and I just I just
right now working on getting a getting
back with a road agent right now
unless you want to take me I like that I
love to do couple I could take women
with me sometimes because a lot of
girlfriends buy tickets for their
boyfriends these girls love them men so
much that they tolerate me before oh
yeah and I always feel bad I go I don't
want to bring two guys because then the
girl feels left out yeah and so a female
left out I want this show for something
I want a woman to go you know what man I
took my [ __ ] [ __ ] husband to see
Joey Diaz he's disgusted
well he's disgusted but Annie Lederman
was really funny and she was also
violent disgusting but she's dead weight
sore night yeah at least you'll say yeah
thing that their wife it's like yeah a
dick one night you know it's so funny
about what you were saying earlier about
people saying like or saying like girls
being like one of the guys or whatever I
always people like you know trolls are
really like its she's just trying to be
one of the or whatever it's like I was
raised with boys like I was raised I
mean I just like I had so much trauma
Chouteau it's like you guys have no
[ __ ] clue there's no like fake I'm
not trying to do anything like this is
how I was raised as a [ __ ] dude I was
raised yeah my natural aura I get energy
from women yeah I can't do anything
without women yeah but we all need each
other I don't want to [ __ ] them yeah I
don't need to [ __ ] em I just need them
around I need that vaginal energy yeah
is an energy that a woman has the [ __ ]
power
you know I was raised by a single mom
who was always surrounded by her [ __ ]
little crazy Nash's friends and I was
telling a woman the other I still
remember but then playing dominoes that
me being her age like watching TV but
listening yeah and the one woman Gong
can you believe my [ __ ] husband he
fell asleep yeah and I eat my [ __ ] all
over huh oh my god what was wrong with
him I don't know he's hanging out with
that guy doing anything right there yeah
I miss that yeah yeah it's my mother and
her friends so my mother once told me my
mother was like 12 or something I mother
like the woman thing
my mother was like when you get ready
they'll come to you you know yeah like
the first time my mom didn't want me to
grow up with your [ __ ] yeah but the first
time I brought a woman oh my mom was
like y'all leave the door open in the
bedroom that will come down and go
what's your [ __ ] problem
yeah I'm trying to get a new key yeah
and she go I'm here yeah we've battled
tore at the door open but my mom used to
always say to me you know what you can't
[ __ ] every woman and happen I might have
to be your friend so you and your
friends knock it off with ya
and I really learned from that I get I
do a lot if six chicks invite me to
watch a football game or five guys I go
to church and I don't wanna [ __ ] these
yeah I just goof yeah I've always
dreamed of that you see that yeah that's
what I always wanted yeah that's what I
love that I love talking to her I know
she's gonna come to me when she's 13 and
say I dated a guy and he fingered me
that's not good yeah yeah you know that
yeah I just went somewhere and a friend
of mine he showed up with his daughter
and he was saying horrible things and
I'm like and he's like oh she knows
everything
no I don't know everything but I want
her to feel comfortable in a certain way
and that's why I always yeah I my y'all
you little [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah with
me you know the Chinese checked because
you figure that's my girl I love a
biggest fan I have pictures of her every
day I go to the [ __ ] Airport to take
pictures of a book I love Ali Wong as
she knows it yeah yeah you know it's
funny when you go out despite you know
you're protected at the store and a
woman you know that if anybody ever lays
a hand on you don't rip it yeah you got
like three guys I went all over you I
went on a date with this guy and he he
said something we were taught where
texting yet we hadn't met yet and he
goes uh said something about my voice I
go oh have you heard my voice before and
he goes no I've never heard your voice
which by the way [ __ ] you hit me up
I'm a comedian you're not gonna check to
see
when my said like you didn't check to
see so he said he'd never heard my voice
he goes well where can I hear your voice
and I was like I don't know did you I
just did you can um I just did a TV
thing you could listen to me on Rogaine
he goes I'd rather not and I go why and
he goes because uh Rogan seems like
someone who would like beat me up for
hitting on a sister and I went he would
only be up if I told him don't like it
but the [ __ ] are you talking about you
[ __ ] what are you [ __ ] [ __ ] I was
like you've never listened to him have
you I have to Abby for the guy around
ten years ago 12 years ago to be exact
and then he tried to clean it up but I
smacked them at the ice off somebody
relay that I sprint this race I smack
the [ __ ] last week she pinched me I
just backhanded argh oh yeah don't come
at me with violence I'm a trained I will
I'm an assassin I will I have a weapon
I have nunchucks Mitchell throw away
your see you slapped a guy I slapped him
at the ice house but I figure out what
the point of the [ __ ] story sorry I
interrupted I'm too [ __ ] hot who
gives a [ __ ] okay it's Monday morning
that's why it's two days before
Christmas and that's it man yeah it is
my family so I would get some dates
there's a giant baby in get you out
there you're a good lady I got a lot of
respect for you what can they find you
with your lips my website is Annie
Lederman led er mancom you can get all
your Annie fix there my dates when I get
them we'll be up there and I have I'll
be on David Spade again on the 9th of
January and I make a lot of videos and
content on Instagram I I love
entertaining people so please follow my
Instagram it's just my name and an IE
led er man
she's very interesting I wouldn't have
her on if she was a Fugazi will be it
will be real deal I'll be funny I'm
gonna head to a toes as you know Colusa
sold out is a few tickets left to San
Francisco at the Palace of Performing
Arts the 16th I got Bakersfield the Fox
Theatre the 17th I got Fresno I don't
know what theater it is and the 25th of
January they add
show the Tabernacle in Atlanta this
tickets out there on Jeff go to joy
beers not net for merch for Christmas
and that's it but real funny bill well
real quickly before we have the podcast
I just want to talk to you about
something listen most of us know how
hard it is and how easy it is to get
into debt you know what hard is getting
out of debt
especially when your credit card score
isn't that great listen to me up start
they offer you a smarter interest rate
to help you pay off your credit card
debt up start is tremendous if you're in
debt right now this is the way to go you
know why because they go beyond the
traditional credit score you're up start
interest rate is based on your education
job history not your credit history they
actually reward you for going to school
up start doesn't care about your bills
you didn't pay five years ago they
really know they care about the person
you are now who you've become and they
give you a rate based on that plus they
make it fast simple and easy to check
your rate in just a few minutes without
affecting your credit score the best
part once the loan is approved most
people get their funds the very next day
the next day over three hundred thousand
people have used up start to pay off
their credit cards free yourself from
the burden of high interest credit card
debt my consolidate and everything into
one this helps I did it for six years
six thirty for a month I had to do it
this is what it is how it works
and you're gonna start one up start so
right now see why I'm start is ranked
number one in that category with over
three hundred businesses on Trustpilot
hurry up start calm slash Church to find
out how low you oughta start rate is
checking your rent only takes a few
minutes and it won't affect your credit
that's right good luck upstart comm
slash Church now as always listen the
worst thing you want us to bump into a
good-looking freak she goes down yes she
lets you ball sack and she smells that
ass for a mile away there's nothing
worse than that hey guys you ever go
down a little woman you just know her
ass before she gets there me I eat it
what the [ __ ] I slam in the Hudson I'm a
soldier at that I don't complain
lucky I'm grateful you give me a piece
they call your tongue the tushy they
don't care
I got a cushy tongue and I got those
whoops I got like a cat tongue she gets
two things for the price of one you know
I'm saying yeah
mercy tell him daddy got a cat tongue
you don't say in any way all right
it's amazing unconventional gift for
anyone in your life everybody has an ass
but everybody deserves a gift from
Turkey you like joy what's do she -
she's affordable the day that you can
install within minutes by yourself no
plumber no nothing let me ask you son
you think wiping your butt with dried
toilet paper does anything no it removes
this [ __ ] but you got poop on the other
part of your body we just we just wipe
it off with a dry paper water cleans
better than dry paper thankfully now
there's a sleek bidet attachment that
slips into the existing toilet and it's
called tushy and it sprinkles your ass
with fresh water all right so she's
pregnant she's not even laughing at me
she's left that no good yeah till she
sprays directly into your muffler and
moves the [ __ ] completely so that you're
not sitting on bacteria you don't have
that spicy ass you know I'm saying and
it creates nasty things like hemorrhoids
yeast infections UTIs itchy [ __ ] the
skidmark you don't need why are you
talking [ __ ] I am right here because
bidets are common all over the world
excepting in the United States they'd
rather kill 10 trees then wash them but
to add water water is the answer until
she sprays fresh water in that muffler
that toilet water the same water you
brush your teeth with all right wet
wipes even worse than toilet paper don't
get me started right listen her she
starts at $69 they come in different
colors
the Toshi's lady's product or tishy
Adelman it's gonna help you get
everything out do me a favor just go to
hell Toshi calm right now look at the
assortment they got think of a 90 day
guarantee on the bidet me and we we've
had a big day for four years if our
[ __ ] haven't broken it your little
skinny little healthy a saying or do
nothing you share the bidet is that one
so go - hello - she calm right now and
press in church and get 10% off your
order this is the perfect Christmas
present
your grandfather grandmother your aunt
they'll sit there their jaw drop and you
get a good laugh and they get to walk
around with a nice [ __ ] instead and
bingo with things developing in their
[ __ ] I want to thank hello - chief
Tom and I want to thank upstart but most
importantly I want to thank you savages
for listening and supporting the podcast
and I want to thank you and wish you
guys a Merry Christmas just in case you
don't listen the Wednesday's I want you
to listen to what I'm telling you right
now I want to wish you a Merry Christmas
and a happy holiday and for you and your
families to be healthy and for you guys
to get ready for 2020 to have a great
new year I am grateful to you guys for
all the support that you've given me
coming to the shows listening and just
interacting with me on Twitter I'm very
grateful for that so go enjoy your day
it's Monday the rules still apply you
stab them on the [ __ ] if they [ __ ] with
you the world ain't gonna give you
nothing for dick and you got the world
by the balls so go out there and get
what's yours
I want to thank Annie Lennon I want to
take the [ __ ] but most
importantly I want to thank you guys I
love you have a great Christmas Eve and
we'll talk in the next couple of days
kick this melee